الملهم ليو ميسي تاثير تجاوز كره القدم
ساو باول البرازيلي يتعاقد رسميا مع
ليونيل ميسي الخبر الصحيح ولكن ميسي
المقصود هنا ليس الاسطوره الارجنتينيه
وانما طفل يبلغ من العمر تسعه اعوام
طفل ولد بالتزامن مع خوض ميسي منافسات كاس
العالم في البرازيل عام 2014 تلك النسخه
التي قاد فيها منتخب بلاده الى ميداليتها
الفضيه حين خسر المباراه النهائيه رغم
تتويجه كافضل لاعب في البطوله وتيمنا
بالاسطوره الارجنتينيه التي حضرت الى
البرازيل سمي ذلك الطفل باسم ليونيل ميسي
قبل ان يصبح لاعب كره قدم ومن يدري الى
اين سيذهب حين يصبح في عمر البولجا في
الحقيقه هذه الحلقه ليست الاولى فيما يخص
التاثير الاجتماعي ليو ميسي والذي سطر
رسمه في قاموس اقليم كتالونيا كاحد
المرجان التي يستخدمها الاباء الجدد قبل
ان يقوموا بتسميه ابنائهم عام 2000 وصل
ميسي الى برشلونه ولم يكن اسمه ليو او
ليونيل منتشرا بين المواليد الجدد في
اقليم كتالونيا حيث اقتصر عدد من اطلقوا
على اطفالهم ذلك الاسم في ذلك العام على
اربعه مواليد جدد ثم ظل يتصاعد حتى وصل في
2004 الى 11 طفلا وفي عام 2019 اصبح اسم
ليو هو ثاني الاسماء الاكثر شيوعا في
كتالونيا بعد اسم مارك حيث انه وفقا
للبيانات الصادره من معهد كتالا في عام
2019 قد تم تسميه طفل باسم ليو في العام
الماضي ظاهره التاثير الاجتماعي لميسي لم
تتوقف عند اسماء المواليد ولم تتوقف
جغرافيا عند حدود الارجنتين وبرشلونه
وانما امتدت لكل العالم بدرجه جعلت مواطنا
برازيليا يسمى ابنه ليونيل ميسي بعد كل
هذه العداوه الكرويه بين البلدين وللدرجه
اكثر جعلت بعض البرازيليين يشجعون
الارجنتين من اجل ان يتوج ليو بكاس العالم
وفقا لاستطلاع راي اجراه المعهد البرازيلي
للابحاث وتحليل البيانات وقت كاس العالم
2022 وضع ثلث المشاركين منتخب الارجنتين
كخيار ثاني في حال لم يستطع منتخب
البرازيل التتويج بكاس العالم وفي بعض
اللقاءات الصحفيه التي اجريت مع المشجعين
ذكر عامل توصيل برازيلي لوكالات فرانسبريس
انه لا يتمنى فوز الارجنتين بالمونديال من
اجلهم ولكن من اجل ميسي وفي دراسه اجرتها
وكاله
في عام 2017 تصدر ميسي قائمه الاشخاص
العشره المؤثرين في الارجنتين متفوقا على
البابا فرانسيس الذي ينتمي الى نفس البلد
ولكنه جاء في المركز الثاني خلفى اليوم
مساحه التاثير تلك وقفت وراء فوز
الارجنتين بكاس العالم حيث ان ميسي اعلن
اعتزاله الدولي في 2016 فتراجع نتيجه
لرسائل الاطفال المتاثرين به كقدوه وقائد
وكانت رسائلهم وراء قرار عدوله عن
الاعتزال حسب ما قاله والطريف ان من بينهم
كان الطفل
الذي مرت عليه سبع سنوات وحقق المونديال
رفقه ليوكزميل له لذلك وبعيدا عما حققه
ليو خلال مسيرته كم سنه من الممكن ان
يحتاجها عشاق الكره حتى تعاد حكايه من تلك
الحكايات التي يظهر فيها البطل الملهم
للملايين بقميص كره قدم